- La population mondiale
continue de croître.
L'ONU estime que151515 novembre
prochain, la planète comptera
8 milliards d'habitants.
entre autres, par l'augmentation
omomombre d'individus
en âge de procréer.
Les progrès en santé ontmememer
l'espérance de vie et à réduire
la mortalité maternelle
et infantile.lelelelelelelelelee
général des Nations unies
écrit entre autres :axaxaxaxaxa)
Les changements climatiques,
les violences et les
discriminations demeurent
des enjeux qui mégégégégégégégér
la planète. En mai dernier, on
comptait plus de 100 millions de
déplacés de force dans le monde.
Alors que la Chine trônait
au sommet alalalmarès des pays
les plus peuplés, les données
démontrent qu'elle se fera
où la population s'élève
,4,4,4 millard de personnes.
Au cours des années à venir,
plus de la moitié de
de la populatiererera
en République démocratique
du Congo, en Égypte,
en Éthiopie, en Inde,
au Nigeria, au Pakistan,
aux Philippines et en Tanzanie.
Pendant que dans les pays
considérés comme étantlalalalalé
est en chute libre.
Quoi qu'il en soit,
la croissance se poursuit.
Le nombre d'huaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaias
en 2050.
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.